here with more Texas governor Greg
Abbott Governor first I applaud your
efforts you've been on this show many
times you've tried convoys you you you
have done everything humanly possible so
your State uh in with its constitutional
right has put up the razor wire they
take you to court on that and now they
set up a confrontation between your
National Guard and federal border troops
now I don't think either side of that
equation wants to be enemies they're all
on the same side aren't
they they are and as you pointed out and
as border patrol Council and border
patrol members have made clear to Texas
and to myself uh they want to have
nothing to do with regard to tearing
down that razor wire or tearing down the
barriers that Texas has erected for one
simple reason and that's because they
are working border patrol says that what
Texas has done to secure the Border
actually makes their job even easier the
the only resistance we're facing is
coming from Joe Biden know this Sean and
that is Joe Biden is in violation of
federal law that already exists for one
he is not living up to his duty to deny
illegal entry across the border instead
he's aiding that illegal entry the
second thing is he's not once people do
cross the border he is not detaining
them as as he's required by law in soad
he's giving Mass parole across the
country because Joe Biden is not
enforcing the Federal immigration laws
that gives Texas the right under that
Article 1 Section 10 of the
Constitution to defend ourselves from
imminent harm or from an invasion so
Texas has every constitutional right in
this case and I believe when the sun
sets on this Texas will be Vindicated
and the Constitution will be
strengthened yeah you know we have
relevant us laws Joe Biden has been
aiding and abetting in the law breaking
Joe Biden i' even go further uh he is he
is violating uh the laws of this country
he is violating his oath up hold our
constitution I could put up on the
screen all you know uh title 8 USC
1324 you know it prohibits alien
smuggling domestic Transportation you
know it goes into you know every
harboring illegal immigrants encouraging
or inducing conspiracy aiding and
abetting if I did any one of the things
that Joe Biden is now institutionalized
I would be in jail and I doubt that the
best lawyers in America could get me off
the
hook well fair point but also you're
making another profound point you listen
to all those different ways that that
the B Administration has these duties
and
responsibilities because they're not
just doing that job poorly but because
they have totally abandoned doing that
job whatsoever that is exactly what
gives Texas our constitutional right for
Texas to be able to act so by by Texas
building the barriers that we have by us
taking the action to repel illegal
immigration we're fully authorized
because the the federal government has
seeded or or conceeded the field of
immigration enforcement and Texas has
picked up that Duty and we're the ones
in self enforcement let me tell you this
amazing number Sean if if you know where
that Park is where Texas now has taken
over and we blockaded that park that is
an area where sometimes over the past
year there would be as many as two or
three or more than that thousand people
coming across the border a day yesterday
there were just six people crossing the
border all six of those people were
arrested by Texas law enforcement
officers we have now cracked down and
been able to staunch the flow of illegal
immigration Biden should want this
replicated across the entire border
that's what Texas is trying to do as we
speak I got to say one good thing your
fellow Republican governor ERS have been
pretty amazing they've all come to your
defense every one of them and they're
offering guard troops they are offering
razor wire they're offering all the help
they they understand that you have
you're bearing the brunt of this but
they also understand that their states
are also uh impacted by uh Joe Biden's
open borders uh and these people are
unvetted as I as I keep pointing out and
and now Joe Biden's being encouraged to
federalize your National Guard your
state guard
um what's what happens if if he tries
that because he did have a deadline a
Friday he hasn't done anything as usual
but what if that happens if he tries to
do that first of all as you know this is
the number one issue in America
Americans want a secure border if Joe
Biden federalizes our national guard
that would be the biggest political
blender that he could make and that's
why I think he will not do it that said
of course I am prepared in the event
that they do make such a blunder to make
sure that Texas will be able to continue
to secure our
border I I I don't I I'm not even going
to ask you what your plan is because I
don't want you to Telegraph it to them
but the fact that you have to you have a
president that has been aiding and ab
betting nearly we're now getting close
to 10 million Joe Biden unvetted illegal
immigrants in this country I can't think
of a bigger danger you you've heard from
these former retired FBI you know people
in the in the upper echelon of the FBI
warning that this is an invasion warning
that these are a lot of these people are
you know men that are of age that they
they could wage war on the country what
are the odds that from these countries
that they're coming from that they have
radical associations and are are setting
up you know sleeper cells here in
America I would say the odds are 100%
myself I hope I'm
wrong well so and so Shan what you just
said Taps into the verb the the words uh
in Article 1 Section 10 Clause 3 where
it talks about imminent danger we are in
imminent danger because as you
rightfully point out these are facts and
that is there are people who are known
terrorists who are coming across the
border that pose an imminent danger
whether it be in Texas or some other
state that because Biden is not doing
his job that fully authorizes the state
of Texas to protect our state and our
country from that imminent
danger yeah Governor I applaud what
you're doing it's unfair that Texas has
to go through this I am glad that your
fellow Republican Governors have all
stepped up and they're offering you um
assistance in any way they can um that
speaks volumes about them I hope the
United
States let me just say let me say thank
you to to my fellow Governors half of
America now is standing against the
Biden Administration also more than a
majority of all the Attorneys General
across the country Biden is not taking
on Texas Biden is taking on the United
States of America
well said and you know what there should
be consequences when a president picks
and chooses the laws that he's going to
enforce and he doesn't get to break the
law uh just cuz he doesn't like the law
uh you've done a great job Governor
under very difficult circumstances and
everybody's uh pulling for you down
there hang in there hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else